[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity Trump's big week while President
Trump continues to make huge foreign
policy gains in the Korean Peninsula and
beyond the molar witch-hunt continues at
home
Kimberly Strasse lat the Wall Street
Journal is out with a bombshell new
piece titled what about that FBI source
did the bureau engage in outright spying
against the 2016 Trump campaign joining
me now to explain more from The Wall
Street Journal is the author of that
piece Kim Strasse Kim thank you so much
for joining us give us the quick
synopsis of what you've found and why
this is so pivotal and so unusual at
this setting well look up until last
week all we knew was that House
Intelligence Chairman Devin noonas had
initiated a new line of inquiry and was
demanding new documents from the
Department of Justice but then in their
desire to make chairman newness look bad
and justify why they were not giving
those documents someone in the
government leaked a lot of details about
what was happening it turns out he's
asking about a top secret government
source who has worked for the FBI and
the CIA who is a US citizen would seem
to have some sort of entanglement with
foreign intelligence agencies or maybe
it's based overseas and based on all
those bread crumbs and some reporting
I've got a pretty good sense of who it
is and it does look as though indeed
there was an FBI attempt a successful
one to basically go out and spy with a
human asset on the Trump campaign no
what about the timing right the timing
about that all of this is critical do we
understand the timing and what are the
implications for that yeah it's so
important because remember the FBI has
been dogged ly sticking with this story
that what initiated this
counterintelligence probe was a tip that
they got in July about this supposed
drunken conversation of a junior
campaign aide need George papadopolis
well if for any reason we find out that
this person this asset of theirs was in
fact surveilling or spying on the Trump
campaign prior to that time
and they've got an issue right because
that's no longer their origin story and
they must have had something else that
they were basing this on whether it be
the dossier or some other information
that they were using as a reason to go
out and surveil the Trump campaign now
how are we going to figure out the
solution of this being every time trey
Gowdy and Devin Nunez and others go over
to the Department of Justice they get
the stiff arm even though there's
subpoenas in place how do they actually
figure this out we we have a great piece
in the journal today by a former FBI
officer just talking and his job was in
fact to fulfill congressional requests
talking about how obnoxious and
outrageous it is that the Department of
Justice is not complying with simple
request much less subpoenas from
Congress and the fact by the way that
they didn't give this information over
to Chairman newness all the way last
year when he said he was investigating
the FBI's conduct is really pretty
striking but look they're gonna have to
Congress as a body and the good news is
chairman ninis looks to have the backing
of all the leadership and the other
members in the Republican Party make it
clear that if the Department of Justice
does not turn this over that they will
move to contempt and with any luck also
the White House is putting out the
message that they need to cooperate and
hand over documents but has it I thought
the White House was actually backing up
the Department of Justice at this point
weren't they well it's interesting the
Department of Justice made quite a big
deal in its letter back to Chairman
newness about how it had this had all
been done in consultation with the White
House but curiously it did agree to sit
down with Chairman newness and I think
probably they have the order to
accommodate him in some way they're
still trying to do it without it getting
out of having to hand over actual
documents but as that is what chairman
newness and others are actually after it
would seem that's what they're gonna
need to hand over to fulfill that
request yeah you know what I as one
who's actually been over to the
Department of Justice and sat in those
meetings and listen to these blowhards
tell me how Congress has no right to see
this stuff and I got to tell you it
really is offensive and at what point do
does the Constitution actually come into
play I mean they don't they give lips
service to oversight but here they are
leaking I mean that's pretty well
documented that they're leaking but what
is it that they think they can't and
shouldn't show to Congress which is the
essentially the American people look you
know this better than anyone we have
processes in place whereby Congress gets
to oversee the executive branch they
can't just say give us everything they
have to have specific cause reason
things that they're looking for and as
this piece we ran today made clear when
those cases came up a Department of
Justice's always helped and been good
about it and we also have processes
whereby in particular the gang of eight
right the senior members of our
intelligence committees the leadership
can see anything in a classified
situation so any arguments that this
should be off-limits are completely
bogus and people should read them for
what they are which is an attempt by the
Department of Justice and the FBI it
would seem to protect something that
they simply don't want people to know
because it might prove embarrassing yeah
and that's really at the heart of it
they prove is embarrassing and I got to
tell you from my vantage point having
been there every member of Congress both
sides of the aisle by the way ought to
be standing behind Devin Oona's and trey
Gowdy and John Radcliffe and those
investigators that are going in there
senator Grassley for instance but Kim's
Drossel is a great piece in The Wall
Street Journal she's one of the best
best writers out there and best
reporters so thank you for joining us
tonight and thanks for that great piece
that you put out